allora partiamo con una corona foto
vediamo
ok sì sto socializzando con lo stile
eccola qui prima foto vi chiedo di
concentrarvi concentrare la vostra
attenzione non tanto sul suo bicchiere
di martini
ma quanto sul suo contenuto
ovviamente lo sto facendo riferimento
alla bellissima dita von teese
ma allo champagne lo champagne e so
perfettamente che questo punto ed hicks
è come dire quando mi è stato chiesto di
raccontare in qualche modo pensare alla
mia narrazione
la prima cosa che ho fatto è stato in
qualche modo pensare in che modo potessi
portarvi la mia storia è l'unico
elemento che ritornava sempre nella mia
narrazione era il vino si il vino il
vino è stato un elemento di straniamento
da un lato ma anche di capovolgimento
del mio percorso professionale ed umano
facciamo un gioco
se dovessi chiedervi ecco assaporate un
goccio di di spumante e un goccio di
champagne
qual è la differenza che le vostre
papille gustative percepirebbero nel
primo caso è il sapore molto più
metallico
nel secondo caso invece lo champagne ha
una sua componente così talmente forte
se volete anche un po ruvida da
lasciarvi sul palato sulle vostre
papille gustative anche un sapore che
sia intenso nello stesso tempo dedicato
la differenza qual è la differenza è nel
metodo nel processo
nel primo caso la fermentazione avviene
in bottiglia in autoclave e quindi un
processo sostanzialmente molto più
stabile nel secondo caso invece il caso
dello champagne
oltre ad essere oltre a essere un vino
raffinato è il processo avviene
attraverso una rifermentazione cioè le
molecole gli atomi gli atomi anno hanno
gli atomi di lievito hanno la capacità
di mettersi in modo di collegarsi agli
zuccheri in un tempo che sembra essere
un tempo abbastanza dilatato ripeto so
che perfettamente questo un the peak è
ovviamente il mio spiccio non intende
riflettere quelli che riflettere su
quelli che sono i termini tipici di
energia ma più che altro di riflettere
insieme con voi quanto un elemento in
questo caso come il vino può essere
contribuire a capovolgere quella che
alla narrazione però abbiamo ancora un
po di tempo quindi io non voglio
arrivare alla fine del mio del mio
speech così velocemente
vi chiedo di guardare questa foto il
processo di sean penn
quello che dicevamo poc'anzi e quindi il
processo che dà vita poi la
rifermentazione a porta alla nascita
dello champagne finisce nel modo più
spettacolare possibile cioè le bottiglie
di champagne e vengono capovolte a testa
in giù e nel capovolgere la per circa
circa due mesi vengono dotate di un
ottavo questo ovviamente che cosa porta
tutte le sostanze residuali le sostanze
vitali a scendere fino al collo della
bottiglia ea fare in modo che quel
perlage diventi quel sapore raffinato
che voi percepite sulle vostre papille
gustative
ecco il capovolgimento e questo è il
momento in cui lo champagne diventa tale
lo champagne diventa come dire assume la
sua caratteristica di essere raffinato
io proverò a fare insieme con voi la
stessa cosa oggi preparare questo ted mi
ha un po messo di fronte allo specchio
guardarmi in questi cinque anni e
guardare il mio percorso la mia
evoluzione in questi cinque anni
io sarò letteralmente la remover della
mia storia
quindi ci sarà un capovolgimento di
prospettiva potrei raccontarvi avrei
potuto raccontarvi sin dall'inizio di re
generation news dei progetti realizzati
dei sogni che in qualche modo ho avuto
il piace
credi di realizzare ed in qualche modo
anche condividere ma voglio fare con voi
un gioco voglio qualche modo capovolgere
riavvolgere il nastro e quindi guardare
dal collo della bottiglia
ovviamente in una prospettiva che a
testa in giù questa foto è abbastanza
emblematica parte la mia giovane età
dimostra anche quello che era un sogno
di quando ero una fanciullina diciamo
che alla veneranda età di 5 anni
io avevo deciso di voler fare
l'archeologa l'archeologa che era in
qualche modo era diventato un nomos
quasi un qualcosa che andava al di là
della passione ho pensato in maniera
permette letterale al fatto che
l'archeologia potesse in qualche modo
essere il mio la mia il mio mestiere
futuro il mio lavoro futuro e quindi
tenete presente che tutta una serie di
termini terminologia che molto complesse
che fanno parte ovviamente del dialetto
e della della terminologia legata
all'archeologia erano un po diventate la
mia la mia casa la mia passione quindi
non mi spaventava più ragionare di quote
altezze misurini traun anzi erano
diventato il mio pane quotidiano
quindi ovviamente tenete presente che
andare alla mia prima lezione di
management di marketing non era proprio
una cosa che mi affascinavano mi
incuriosiva per nulla anzi mi mi mi
faceva in qualche modo tremare il solo
pensiero di entrare in quell'aula e
invece nel momento in cui io sono
entrata in quell'aula ho visto quella
bottiglia di vino in qualche modo ho
capito che la mia narrazione sarebbe
stata sostanzialmente invertita in quel
momento quello che era stato il percorso
tracciato fino ad allora è stato
totalmente stravolto
stavolta è quindi un nome il nome che un
po ha caratterizzato la mia vita fino a
quel momento è stato spazzato via
mi sono avventurata mi sono avventurata
in un percorso che ha qualche modo a un
po sconvolto i miei genitori no quindi
se chiama che un giorno e sono da fra
loro e top ma io non voglio fare più
l'archeologa sul loro volto c'è stato
abbassa c'è stato uno shock bello forte
no quindi a
non può più fare l'archeologa e quindi è
quindi iniziata una domanda che
praticamente un riff costante della mia
vita
sì ma che lavoro fai mi avevano ancora
vi chiedersi giusti ma tu che il lavoro
fa e non che lavoro fai
io questa questa domanda sto cercando di
dare una risposta e spero di farlo con
voi questa sera come vi dicevo prima
percorrere un percorso che ovviamente è
nuovo è il rischio di gli ostacoli di in
siria di insite porta anche a tener
presente una sfida importante l'intuito
ma anche distinto nella mia vita
l'istinto ha sempre prevalso sulle mie
scelte professionali e ovviamente anche
anche umane l'altro elemento che ha
sempre caratterizzato poi il mio
percorso professionale sono quelle che
definisco le peregrinazioni cioè gli
scambi l'aver veramente come dire
proceduto quasi a passo più a posto
spiritismo aver macinato chilometri e
chilometri avere incontrato in questi
cinque anni tantissime persone
tantissime esperienze con le quali
ovviamente sono nate connessioni
straordinarie sono nate connessioni
straordinarie e hanno fatto in modo che
io in qualche modo capovolgesse sempre
di più la mia narrazione di un ottavo
la rete è stata determinante non solo
per mettere a frutto quelli che sono
collegano le mie idee le mie volontà i
miei sogni i miei progetti ma anche per
farmi rendere conto di quelli che erano
un po di quelle che erano un po le
vicissitudini a cui andava in cui
incontrò gli ho raccontato un percorso
sicuramente interessante spero fino fino
ad ora ma la strada non è stata tutta in
discesa
anzi la stata è stata in salita
ripidissima ho incontrato le prime
discriminazioni generazionale e di
genere
sapesse quante volte a 25 anni mi sono
detto vabbè ma tu sei una donna se
giovanissima e quindi questi dati sono
quanto più attuali 2014 2019 questi dati
ci fanno riflettere in maniera secondo
me è molto chiara di quanto di quanto le
donne le ragazze siano costantemente
discriminate rispetto ovviamente alla
componente alla componente
di quanto ancora 2019 il dato che ci
riportano i dati i dati dell'istat ci
parlano di quanto il tasso di
occupazione sia inferiore di 18 punti
rispetto a quello maschile
vogliamo parlare poi del gap salariale
una donna riesce a guadagnare all'anno
un massimo di 5 25 mila euro lordi
rispetto invece quasi il doppio che
riescono come dire a portare a casa a
portare a casa gli uomini e quindi
questo sicuramente ha fatto muovere un
po le prime le mie prime sensazioni
quello che in qualche modo erano delle
fiammelle dentro di me
l'altra cosa che è stata determinante
che mi sono riportata sempre nel mio
percorso professionale e questa frase
della mia docente di museologia che io
voglio letteralmente scagliarvi la rete
è stata la garanzia non solo della mia
libertà di azione
ovviamente anche di una prospettiva
lavorativa sicuramente interessante ecco
quello che vi dicevo prima il processo
di champagne
ci stiamo affidando in qualche modo
stiamo arrivando alla parte conclusiva
alla parte del the course mano cioè
finale quando c'è la spuma finale e lo
champagne diventa come dire raffinato
fino fino alla fine
io ho percepito ho perseguito dentro di
me l'esigenza di dover dare non solo
credito sfogo a quelli che erano dei
pensieri a quelli che erano delle
intuizioni ma farlo anche attraverso
qualcosa di concreto e per questo vi
dico che una serie di busi una serie tv
letteralmente non una tra le più famose
the bold type è stata determinante per
farmi capire e far portare avanti quello
che poi è stato il progetto il progetto
re generation news re generation of che
è un progetto un thinktank tutto quanto
al femminile che ho il piacere di
guidare grazie a 9 validissime amiche e
collaboratrici e professionista che
muove sostanzialmente i passi tenendo
presente due considerazioni il primo di
muoversi attraverso un approccio di tipo
bottom up dal basso verso l'alto quindi
guidare dei progetti dei progetti e dei
processi dal basso verso l'alto e poi
attraverso un approccio di tipo granze
di finale
uno dei progetti che mi sta più a cuore
e wii ma nel calcio quindi da un lato
mappare le donne che stanno ottenendo un
ruolo di leadership nel settore creativo
e culturale e dall'altra la
positivissima esperienza che abbiamo
concluso un mese e mezzo fa maratea che
ci ha portato in qualche modo ha portato
le donne a mettersi in gioco attraverso
attività di mentorship attraverso
formazione e soprattutto a credere in se
stesse credere di essere delle
imprenditrici che agiscono nel settore
culturale e creativo
io penso che la narrazione fino a questo
momento sia stata spero di vostro
gradimento raccontarvi re generation
dall'inizio voleva dire ovviamente
significava dire non solo raccontarvi
quello che era la fine avreste in
qualche modo tolto al vostro dalla
vostra testa quello che invece è stato
il mio percorso professionale
sostanzialmente la bellezza di
regeneration dei progetti portati avanti
di regione del sud è stato possibile
solo solo perché in qualche modo la
narrazione è stata capovolta perché voi
vi siete cava volte insieme a me l'avete
guardata a testa in giù finisco il mio
spicciola somma di queste che sono delle
frasi tratte da un periodo tratto dal
saggio di virginia woolf una stanza
tutta per sé
vi prego di leggere di capirne il
significato parola per parola perché per
me sono stati determinanti
quello che dico di quale giovani donne
in questa sala e non solo di avere il
coraggio di parlare il coraggio di dire
le cose ad alta voce non avere paura
delle proprie fragilità e soprattutto
avere il coraggio di lasciare le strade
tracciate
vi prego fatelo lasciate le strade che
avete già che qualcuno ha già
preimpostato per voi fregate avere
quando vi dicono ma che lavoro fai
perché il lavoro dentro di voi sapete
perfettamente a cosa state
qual è il vostro percorso che cosa sta
andando incontro
l'ultima cosa credete nella rete credete
nel fatto che le donne possono e devono
fare rete perché fidatevi è l'unico
strumento che vi renderà sempre libere e
soprattutto cittadini attivi del nostro
tempo
grazie
[Applauso]